most of the people who were teaching
them who are listening to this thing
would not hire themselves the intensity
that you have it has to be in everything
you do you have to be an intense person
everybody loves you when things are
going great but you really get to see
who you are who the real people around
you are what things are
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
out of the world now he started the
believe life series to once a week
tackle topics a little outside of just
the world of entrepreneurship and
business so to help you live your best
believe life today we're gonna look at
the top ten life tips that you should be
informed about joy
[Music]
alright let's kick it off with tip
number one thicken your skin with David
Goggins you will never learn from people
if we always tap-dance around the truth
oh god I love that we tap-dance around
the truth by finding the right words I
don't hurt you because you have thin
skin no tighten up people it's okay
trust me it's okay you might be called
[ __ ] one day it's okay you might be
called some Jewish word or some [ __ ]
or gay word it's okay
let them call you that what are you
going to do now they don't own your life
how are you going to control that now
how are you going to flip it upside down
and say Roger that
now I'm going to harness this and you
read about me years from now how that's
the question how are you going to do
that thicken your skin become more of a
human being don't be afraid of the
reflection in the mirror because that's
all you can be afraid of once you
overcome the reflection in the mirror
you've done it tip number two discipline
yourself with Eric Thomas as I was like
yo you got to discipline yourself I
started looking at mother Teresa of
Ghandi and I was like yo bro Gandhi
would go fast from sex and he was
married he would fast from talking you
know I just started watching these great
peoples like all these people fast and
not about fast and like that's not the
piece but they were very disciplined
people and they would not allow their
exterior world to dominate or destroy
their internal world I just like you I
want to get to a place where I can
control me my family members have grown
a loss too uncle cirrhosis of the liver
brilliant man but just drinking drinking
drinking and I was like yo I do not want
to my father was a substance abuser for
years I was like yo I don't want a life
where something else is controlling me
you know like when I left home and said
I don't want to be controlled no more
like I meant that like I don't know
nothing to control me but me and so I
got to put myself under extreme
discipline to make sure I'm free so when
people see me you get up at 3 you don't
drink your own smoke I'm not doing that
because I think I'm better no bye
oh I think you're gonna go to hell
because you had a drink I just want I
want to control I want freedom and for
me disciplining myself means more
freedom and unless I you discipline
yourself people who I told my son other
dads like your son
I do not want you to have fun I just
seen a history of people who just have
fun Christmas Thanksgiving Halloween no
there are the people learns that not
every night there are the people who end
up in a 20s having a great deal of fun
but in a 40s and 50s they working for
somebody and I'm not saying nothing
wrong with cleaning toilets but they
doing something they don't want to do
for the rest of their life and they
can't retire because they played so much
you know so for me I just look at Venus
in Sarina Michael Jackson when he used
to like five and sixes dancing all night
I just think the more man discipline
himself the greater you don't mean it's
gonna happen but the greater the
probability that he has this sense of
freedom tip number three don't let fear
paralyze you with Elon Musk or unusually
fearless and willing to go in the face
of other people telling you something
that's crazy
and I know a lot of pretty crazy people
you still stand out where does that come
from or how do you think about making a
decision when everyone tells you this is
a crazy idea where do you get the
internal strength to do that well first
of all I'd say I actually think I feel
feel fair quite strongly so it's not as
though I just have the absence of fear
I've I feel it quite strongly but there
were times when if something is
important enough you believe it enough
that you do it in spite of the fear so
speaking of important things like people
shouldn't think III I should if you
should think well I feel fear about this
and therefore I shouldn't do it it's
normal to be to feel fair like you'd
have to do something mentally wrong you
shouldn't feel fair so you just feel it
and let the importance of it drive you
to do it anyway yeah you know actually
we're something that can be helpful as
fatalism some degree if you just think
it's just accept the probabilities then
that diminishes fear so
my starting SpaceX I thought the odds of
success were less than 10% and I just
accepted that actually probably I would
just lose lose everything
but that maybe would make some progress
if we could just move the ball forward
even if we died maybe some other company
could pick up the baton and move and
keep moving it forward so that were
slowly some good yeah same with Tesla I
thought your odds of a car company
succeeding were extremely low tip number
four treat yourself like you matter with
Jordan Peterson first of all you have to
treat yourself like you matter because
if you don't then you don't take care of
yourself and you become vengeful and and
and cruel and you you take you take it
out on people around you and you're not
a positive force none of that's good so
you suffer more and so does everyone
around you and there's a malevolence
that enters into it none of that's good
so that's what happens if you don't
treat yourself like you matter and then
what happens if you don't treat other
people like they matter
well you lie to them you cheat them you
steal you you you enter into impulsive
relationships with them they can't trust
you that doesn't go anywhere they don't
like you you you end up alone at best
and maybe like incarcerated at worst
like that doesn't work and so you watch
the people around you who thrive
regardless of what they say they act out
the proposition that everyone matters
and then you have a functional society
and I think ok well if if if when you
act out the proposition that everyone
matters you have a functional society
maybe that's evidence that that
proposition is true it's like I think
it's I think it's true tip number five
spend more time learning with Patrick be
David I want you to go on your YouTube
channel and forget about if you don't
have a youtube channel go on the search
button above and click on history and
watch the last 20 videos you have
watched on YouTube and this is what I
want you to do categorize the videos on
which ones of them are educational and
which ones are entertainment if 50
percent or more of the videos are
entertainment you're not really fully
committed to want it to become wealthy
you're more
to become entertained and it's not going
to happen go on YouTube and look the top
1000 videos keep going until you find
the first video that has to do with a
how to you know how many videos are
ahead hundreds if not thousands because
most of the world doesn't care about
wanting to fully found the secrets about
business and life and entrepreneurship
they want to be entertained this is why
Hollywood makes so much money because
they know most of the world it's fully
just committed to an entertainment that
maybe you go look at your search by the
way you can go on your history also on
your Google and look what what's that
you visit and what you do with your time
that you have tip number six act like an
on commodity with Seth Godin most of the
people who were teaching right now who
are listening to this thing would not
hire themselves that if you had to pick
someone in the world to do it the thing
that you do you'd find someone better
than you so we've changed the stakes and
we have to be really clear about that it
used to be if you went to Rhode Island
School of Design and you got through it
you had this huge head start on people
that starts are gone yes so when you
think about it you know when when term
says I'm a freelancer and my primary
asset is my relationship with my clients
well if I went and asked your clients
which of all the freelancers you work
with is off-the-charts with the
relationship would they actually pick
you this person right that when someone
says I'm able to use light in color to
create photographs that create an
indelible image in people's heads well
if I talk to the people have seen it are
you really off the charts so what I'm
saying is yes this institution is
crumbling but that puts a huge onus on
people to be honest with themselves
about the craft that you're not going to
get away with the craft being what it
used to be just because we could find
you and you know I gave a talk two weeks
ago to the people who make all the
imprinted items in the country like pens
and the water bottles things like the
huge industry there's 50,000 a hundred
thousand people who do this for a living
ninety percent of them have a big thick
catalog they'll have the same catalog
and the same price list and you go to
them and they say yeah I have these
water bottles which one do you want that
used to be
the important value add because there
was no internet but now there's the
internet sort by price I'll take this
water bottle I'm done ten percent of the
people actually engage with you help you
find it that you never would have
thought of deliver the thing that's off
the charts are taking huge emotional
risks as they do their work the other
ninety percent are sitting there
thinking and they are in the ten percent
they're not they just have a catalogue
so sometimes people throw things at me
when I'm on stage because my argument is
I didn't wish for the world to change
but it did
now that the world has changed don't get
frustrated because people are doing
exactly what you do shopping around
sorting by price buying commodities
because that's what we do when we're
given the choice so if you want to be
treated as an on commodity act like an
on commodity no one is a commodity if
they don't want to be tip number seven
don't make any excuses with Gary
Vaynerchuk I know you helped a lot of
people start especially younger people
but how does a person with four kids yes
him right now doesn't like his job yeah
but just can't quit and sell stuff yeah
I'll find stuff in a junkyard so if
you're listening and you're over 42
let's just use my age there's something
interesting you said something that I
helped a lot of people that are younger
it only has to do with one thing they
actually believe in the technology we
live in right this room is filled with
guys right now who've taken advantage of
YouTube or Instagram or just the
Facebook's of the world and the only
thing I need to do to break through
somebody who's 47 in the suburbs of
London who has a mortgage debt and three
children is for them to understand that
unlike when he or she and I grew up and
there was no internet the thought of
like having a happy life was separate
than taking care of what you were
supposed to take care of the fact that
everybody can come home tonight at 6 7 8
9 p.m. and then take out their phone or
their iPad or whatever and get to work
for 3 more hours and go to sleep at
midnight get their good six or seven
hours of sleep I'm not talking about
don't sleep a lot of people get me
confused my big thing is if you're not
happy if you're happy
and you make 37,000 pounds a year Mazel
Tov
do you but if you are
not happy if you hate your job right you
can do something about it instead of
blaming brexit or blaming Trump or
blaming your mom like do something about
it and my point is it's the Internet
tip number eight do everything with
intensity with Tim Grover so we're both
workout guys we like to go - that would
be like that we like to go to the gym
all right how many times have you seen
people in the gym they spend more time
on their playlist taking pictures doing
stuff aesthetic getting their work
instead of getting their workout done so
true it's just like you know and here's
the thing all right you're a very
intense person I can tell okay I'm a
very intensive worsen you're fine
we value our time yes all day how do you
get results in the gym
it isn't about spending two to three
hours working out people say I spent
three hours you didn't spend three out
human by time you pulled into the
parking lot the by timing change got
some breakfast
put your workout clothes on talked to
eight people then all that stuff you
were there for you were there for three
hours you did you did you that you did
your three hours no intensity yeah all
right all right people talk about hey
hey you know you post a couple workout
things you see any your buff guy or
you're next you're in a great shape all
right people said and I want to look
like I want to look like you all right
they don't see what it takes to look
like you not only in the gym outside of
the gym the intensity that's there
you're in the gym and I'm assuming you
workout with music you had some
headphones on you got to get a certain
amount of stuff done in a certain amount
of time all right you're in this
intensive somebody comes up to you yeah
okay and you don't want to be rude to
them see now you take your headphones
off they ask you a question they want to
take a picture with you oh I recognize
you from so and so on all right and then
then their questions how do I get to
look like well the one way you get to
look like me is leave me there alone
and start hitting sign in the wait start
start lifting yeah it's the intensity
that you have it has to be in everything
you do you have to be an intense person
in your workouts the way you did the way
you eat okay that's that's intensity how
do how do you fuel up your metabolism
rate so you burn in these calories so
you can get that definition that's
intent that's an intensity how do you
get to be successful you know the old
man he he or she he's so intense no you
know what he and she that's how you're
supposed to be you're at a different
level right and that's why I said the
intensity is so it's so important it's
what really separates those individuals
and you can't get into that zone and you
can't get arms and abs like Edie
or you can't do it unless you have that
intensity and you're willing to block
out the distractions we have so much
access now to information yeah there's
literally at our fingertips
you know everything okay why are more
individuals doing less you're right
because they're easily distracted tip
number nine you need to find mentors
with Tai Lopez the thought that people
argue with me on this reading thing and
people argue with me about Mentors
no just use your own gut feeling is that
how you learn English when you were two
years old you use your gut feeling to
start conjugating verbs no you learn
from other people you learn manners you
learn language you learn all things
valuable you learn to drive from another
person so it doesn't make sense you
learn life so books are just the mentors
who maybe are dead now you wanna learn
about Steve Jobs being alive the teacher
but you can learn through accumulated
wisdom and that's what trust me I've
meet I very few powerful businessman
I've ever met
don't read a lot Warren Buffett who I
think's the best businessman by far in
the world has done see has 75 companies
that he pretty much runs 200 billion in
revenue he reads eight hours a day
he reads 600 he said he slowed down in
his old age I only reads 500 pages a day
Bill Gates goes on reading vacations
Mark Zuckerberg just start started a
reading once a week book club on
Facebook
could already got a couple million
fathers and now with audiobooks there's
no excuse you got YouTube videos let
this thing run in the background like
you want to become like a super computer
you just download smart crap from smart
people and you pick and choose like some
people are like ty I don't agree with
everything you say I'm like good I don't
agree with everything I said like a year
later I'm like wait I was wrong I see
people making fun of the Kardashians I'm
like you gonna make fun of the
Kardashians look Kylie Jenner the
youngest Kardashian in the last 18
months has done four hundred million
dollars in revenue on lipstick kits and
various make up things with Kylie
cosmetics put that in perspective
Lauria maybelline massive brands it took
them fifty years as an organization with
thousands of employees to do a Kylie
Jenner did by herself at 20 at 18 you're
gonna laugh at the Kardashians do you
have to agree with everything that
Kardashians know but like Abraham
Lincoln said I learned from everybody
even if sometimes it's what not to do so
you can just go into the Kardashians
reverse-engineer their success go I like
this I like this I like this I don't
like that then leave out what you don't
like and tip number ten the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
maintain good relationships with Kevin
Hart one thing is you better stay true
to in his businesses relationships you
know you're gonna meet a lot of people
and in Hollywood everybody appears to be
real men but it's a facade you got to be
a great character and a great judgment
of character you know everybody loves
you when things are going great but you
really get to see who you are who the
real people around you are when things
aren't and those people that you can
tell a real you hold on to you know you
stayed true to those relationships
because there's gonna come to a point
where you go damn what do I have out
here with substance do I have out here
if it's not a party it was not a
nightclub if you're not in a
relationship what matters it's only
gonna be about a good five or six people
that actually matter and those five or
six people are gonna be there for you
whenever you need them and the favors
that I called on those are long-term
relationships man but I don't
many you know I got friends in the
business that are really my friends but
I pride myself on the 10 to 12 that I
have because they're genuine they're
real everything else just comes off as
an associate it's something that moves
when you move in a high-end buy but
those real ones are real for a reason
because when you call they respond
I've got a very special bonus clip from
Satguru on how to take a holiday from
seriousness but before that I want to
know which of these top ten life tips
resonated the most with you which do you
need to apply the most to your life
leave it down in the comments below I'm
really curious to find out also is there
eleven twelve thirteen that you want to
add to the list let me know thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
just loosen up your life a little bit
laugh a little more involve yourself
with people around you do things that
you think is not so important don't do
things which are very important do
simple things very important you do
simple things very important things
you're doing in your life you will
become dead serious
you know Bertrand Russell and Englishman
Bertrand Russell said if you're
beginning to think that what you are
doing is very important you need to take
a holiday
so holiday does not mean coming to
Indiana holiday is every day in those 24
hours you must take a holiday from your
seriousness from yourself seriousness
has come essentially because of your
self-importance you hold yourself as an
important person I want you to see you
are like a speck of dust in this
existence tomorrow morning if you
disappear for sure in India nobody will
miss you even Down Under they won't
bother much you know a handful of people
they will also forget soon enough isn't
it sir ooh
nature does woof you're gone and nothing
will happen in this world everything
will happen wonderfully well even if
you're not they every human being should
be aware of this every moment of his
life it does not matter what the whole
world says about you it does not matter
how significant the work you're doing
you must understand that tomorrow
morning the world will go on fine
without you whoever you may be isn't it
so
if you constantly remind yourself of
this you'll have no reason to be serious
[Music]
definitely not dead
and don't be dead now a time will come
it's time to be alive raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that we move that people need
passion and now one drop of my
self-worth depends on Europe it's
suppose to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details